في المرحله الحاده يمكن ان نلاحظ اعراض
كالتوتر الخوف القلق ترابات النوم فقدان
القدره على النوم ضعف الشهيه للطعام
عاده ان نجد ان اعراض تخف خلال عده اسابيع
او شهر او شهرين عاده اكثر من شهرين هناك
من يقول شهر يعني ربما تكون قد دخلت في
حاله من الاضطراب النفسي وطبعا اذا طالت
الاعراض هنا النصيحه انه ما اخذ من استشار
[موسيقى]
هناك ما نسميه الدعم النفسي الاجتماعي
والذي يمكن ان يقدمه الانسان العادي غير
المتخصص
كالتفريغ العاطفي عن طريق اللعب وخاصه
الاطفال والمراهقين الرسم الاناشيد
الاغاني كل هذه الاشياء
تعين الانسان على تعبير عن عواطفه يعني ما
يكبت في نفسه مشاعره وعواطفه ومخاوفه
الذي لم تتطور عنده الاعراض
لاضطراب او مرض نفسي فيكفي مجرد دعم
النفسي الاجتماعي وتامين حاجاته الاساسيه
من ماوى ومشرب ومسكن